don't forget that it's going to be a
windy tuesday we're already seeing dust
out there kiddos hang on to the homework
today 60 degrees it's amazingly mild
this morning but we've had gusty winds
and clouds overnight but those clouds
are clearing out for the most part this
morning they will be back later today
clouds in the afternoon and those strong
winds are going to be around even when
you're out on the playground and when
you're heading home from school
temperatures today only in the mid 60s
for highs that's it 55 mile an hour
winds that was at 3 30 this morning out
at red rock mountain springs summit also
quite windy near 50 mile an hour winds
and so many areas that will have 35 40
plus mile an hour winds temperatures
mainly in the 60s only a few west valley
neighborhoods in the 50's and up in the
north end of the valley outside the
valley prompt you've had quite a bit of
wind at 57 degrees right now 43 at
indian springs not much wind in laughlin
or mesquite temperatures in the 50s
there freezing in caliente and up in
reno it's snow up in western nevada
around this low pressure system which is
bringing snow up north but a whole lot
of wind down south and wind advisories
will start in just a little over 10
minutes from now for all of these areas
in blue across southern nevada we're
looking at 20 to 30 mile per hour
sustained winds today with gusts over 40
for most areas in some areas as we've
already seen over 50 miles an hour it
lasts until 7 p.m
until 4 a.m tomorrow for southern nye
county mount charleston will be looking
for an increasing chance of rain and
snow
above 4 500 feet late today into tonight
highs in the 40s up there today mid 60s
for the valley and late day chances for
rain and into tonight a better chance
not a lot of measurable rain but boy if
we could get any kind of showers we
certainly need it we'll take it breezy
but sunny for the next couple of days
highs in the mid 60s which is really
just still a little above normal a
beautiful saturday and sunday but
presidents day monday another system
gusty winds clouds maybe even a chance
of showers again and cooler highs in the
50's wow